Michael thanks for being here so my
understanding of the First Amendment is
it that's not there to protect the easy
speech it's there to protect the stuff
we don't like why don't kids get that of
course if the First Amendment doesn't
protect so-called hate speech then
what's the point of it you don't need a
constitutional amendment to protect
popular speech you need it to protect
speech that is unpopular which some
people might define is hateful but then
who's the one who's doing that defining
the problem here is primarily one of
ignorance Thomas Jefferson said that a
nation that wants to remain ignorant and
free in a state of civilization is
hoping for something that never was and
never will be but according to another
survey just 40 percent of Americans and
can name any of the rights protected by
the First Amendment
only 56 percent know that the First
Amendment protects free speech this is a
problem primarily of ignorance another
survey showed that students graduating
from elite colleges know less about
their civics less about their government
than they did when they were going in as
President Reagan said freedom is not
passed in the bloodstream you have to
teach the next generation if you don't
do it we're gonna lose it very soon
Michael you've seen this firsthand
but you mentioned Thomas Jefferson you
know he's not you can't have him anymore
they're protesting him but you talked
about it's ultimately who's doing the
deciding who's the one that decides
what's hate speech and in our
politically correct world which it often
is who is making that call of course
when I was physically assaulted at the
University of Missouri Kansas City the
phrase that was considered hate speech
is the phrase men are not women if you
say I gave another speech at Cal State
LA I said that the United States should
have national borders I was protested
and told that that was hate speech it's
always a subjective question when it
comes to what is hate speech and
therefore what shouldn't be protected
the argument that they make is that
certain speech is violent and it harms
people but actually there was a study
last year 2018 that showed that
so-called trigger warnings and safe
spaces and all of this censorship is
actually harming the students that it
intends to help because it leaves them
psychologically fragile and they should
learn that sticks
stones may break my bones but words will
never hurt me Michael I'll go out on a
limb and say you are a man
maybe the man okay Michael thank you
very much for time we appreciate I
appreciate a peep